foreign
I said something offhanded in response
to Joe Rogan a couple weeks back
was that a couple weeks boy it doesn't
feel like it but I think it must have
been a week and a half yeah a week and a
half something like that anyway he asked
me a question I've now forgotten what it
was about antibodies
um and I said to him I said look I think
the co the um concept of antibodies has
loomed way too large in the public
Conversation Over immunity in the
context of covid and my guess is that
the reason
we have focused on antibodies is because
the public knows what an antibody is yes
agree to kind of loosely but
um but the point is when you say
antibody
um it immediately conjures something
right whereas you know if you talked
about almost any other kinds of if I say
clonal selection right which is a you
know fundamental Concept in Immunology
almost nobody knows what you're talking
about so
I do think that this is
it's almost a tell that suggests that
what we are faced with is propaganda
so I don't I haven't I haven't listened
to that part it's a clip and I'm so I
may stop me if this just isn't making no
sense at all but but so your argument is
that maybe part of the reason that we're
talking about antibodies so much is
simply because
the the
um the public already knows what they
are and so it's sort of ready to receive
this sort of talk but it feels to me
like it's also true and I haven't gone
back and reviewed this at all so it may
be wrong here but it's also true uh that
antibodies are easier to to find in in
the body like they're easier to test for
than say t cells and so you know we have
we have
clinical tests that find the thing
that's easy to measure and the people
already know about so I mean it feels
like it could be both and unless I'm
wrong but but no you're not just right
like right you're not wrong it's an easy
it's an easy essay it's an easy yeah PCR
and it's the it's the wrong thing to be
doing right uh for for a number of
reasons but uh those those two reasons
which have nothing to do with whether or
not they're the right thing make it the
easy and
um publicly amenable thing to be talking
about yeah I get it right
um it's something that we can talk about
because we're more likely to have
information about it because it's easier
to come by that information it's less
arduous I don't think that's really
driving this
um at all in fact we can see even in the
recent testing that was used I think it
was for the eua for the childhood uh
so-called vaccines where they had
measured
antibodies and claimed that that implied
that these were very good at creating
immunity to Modern variants and the
point is there was a giant leap in there
right which is it's not clear first of
all antibodies aren't what people think
right this is you're peering into a
complex system and you were able to
identify something and that is resulting
you saying oh there are a whole bunch of
antibodies and it doesn't inherently
mean anything in fact antibodies can be
negative they can make the disease more
capable of getting into your cells so
um anyway I do feel like it is
indicative of the propagandistic nature
of our discussion that we are being
presented with something that can then
you know emerge into the conversation
where people are then talking to each
other about antibodies because they know
a little something about antibodies
whereas if you were talking about
receptors on a T Cell they'd be
scratching their heads what's the
receptor what is a T Cell why would a
receptor be useful in this battle you
know so anyway there is something weird
about the focus on on antibodies
and so anyway off the cuff said to Joe
that I think it's about the uh the fact
that the public knows what they are
rather than the fact that that's where
the conversation should be centered and
uh then a friend of ours uh Jimmy Kim
pursued this question I did ask her and
she was at least somewhat uh inspired to
look into it because of my comment to
Joe
um but anyway what she came up with is
very interesting and I'll just sort of
loosely say what it is I would suggest
everybody check out hey Zach can you
show uh Jimmy sub stack post
um so I would suggest people uh check
out her sub stack she has done a bunch
of these deep Dives and she's very good
at doing this in plain English so that
it's very accessible she's highly
capable as a biologist so the technical
matter is all right she's not cheating
on the technical stuff but she presents
it in a way you can understand why she
reaches the conclusion she does she
presents with the references so anyways
it's really good stuff yeah and for
those just listening her sub stack is
called let's be clear it's really quite
excellent it really is quite excellent
um so anyway what she
discusses in here is all of the little
threads of evidence that suggest that uh
at the very least antibodies are not the
um the end-all and be-all of immunity to
covid and she goes through some evidence
that I was frankly unaware of now that
I've seen her explore it yeah I would
have I should have wondered if the if
the evidence existed in this form but if
people who can't produce antibodies for
one of a number of reasons either
because they're on a drug that is
suppressing their production of
antibodies or they have a congenital
defect that causes them not to be
producing antibodies and as she
correctly points out the fact that these
people are not doomed by covid means
they are successfully fending it off
which implies a whole other system that
is not captured in the oh my God it
creates a great titer of antibodies
um so anyway those who are more deeply
knowledgeable about Immunology will spot
at least one of the other components of
that system which is the um we basically
have two kinds of circulating cells that
manage this very specific kind of
immunity right that is an adaptive
immunity that learns to fend off a
pathogen right
we have B cells B cells have receptors
on them and they produce free-floating
antibodies those two things have a
relationship so when a receptor is
triggered by an antigen then the release
of antibodies occurs in at least many
cases whereas a T cell produces no
free-floating antibodies it has
receptors it gets triggered and they
create lots of other phenomena they can
for example people will remember our
discussion from I think last week and
many other times where we discussed the
question of what happens when your own
cell is producing not only your own
antigens but is producing foreign
antigens well that cell gets destroyed
the body destroys it and it destroys it
using T cells these T cells identify
this compromised cell they in any
natural case that I know of
a cell that is producing foreign
antigens and self antigens is an
infected cell and so killing it is the
way to get rid of it right it's bad to
kill your own cells but it's better to
do that than leave them in place so
anyway you've got these two different
systems and so the fact that the B cell
antibody based immunity is not the sum
total of covet immunity clearly is
evidenced by I mean it is never right
for any
for any illness for any pathogen
response is it ever entirely b-cell well
there will be things that are primarily
B cell so for example what are the
conditions that uh predict
good question
um this is off the top of my head having
studied this many many years ago and you
know as an undergraduate in a medical
school class but nonetheless it's been a
long time and uh the field has grown and
I've learned a lot during Kobe that I
didn't learn back then but uh but for
example if you had a bacterium
right you might there's some bacteria
that you might fend off by just gumming
them up with antibodies that would then
cause them to be consumed by macrophages
right that might be the go-to mechanism
and because the bacterium is not getting
into your cells T cells might be uh none
of the response or not primary so you
know I hesitate to say anything
in absolute terms in biology because as
as my advisor and and uh member of your
committee Dick Alexander would always
say is like you know that's the quickest
route to be wrong because biology you
know
he used to make this point about insect
that anything you think never happens in
animals check out insects you'll find
it's there somewhere yeah
um
well it's a it seems like one
Trend that for which there will be
exceptions will be that uh single acute
exposure to something uh might be your
body might launch a successful immune
response uh entirely or almost entirely
with B cells and eradicate it and if
you're not exposed to it again like it's
it's gone right now this is actually
covers one of the things so my purpose
today is to actually just get people
used to hearing about this because I
have a feeling where the conversation is
about to go is hey is this antibody
stuff really what we've been led to
believe or is it being used to Mesmerize
us when there's a larger conversation
that might say something very different
right and so
um one thing that is the case right
people have a I'm now understanding
people have a misunderstanding in their
mind about antibodies being the result
of either
uh natural immunity developed in
response to infection
uh or
um
um or vaccination acquired immunity from
a vaccination for instance and what this
misses is that in fact and
forgive me if you've heard this before
but there is a system that has a
rudimentary set of cells that are not
highly effective at attacking any
pathogen they haven't seen but have a
basic ability to attack anything that
isn't self right and so the point is it
is wrong if what you've got in your mind
is oh I need something to create
antibodies and I'm not going to have
that until I've been infected with the
pathogen or I've gotten a vaccine let's
say a classic vaccine that does this
well that's not really right what
happens if you get infected with a
pathogen that you have never seen before
is a process of evolution is triggered
inside your immune system and what
literally happens and I believe it is
the most interesting biological fact I
am aware of but what happens is
your cells be they be or T cells or both
literally evolve they evolve on the time
scale that pathogens evolve and they do
so what they do is they take that crude
ability to uh electromagnetically attach
right or to be triggered in the case of
a receptor they take that crude ability
and they refine it and the way they do
this is through something called clonal
selection where those that tiny subset
of your immune cells that is triggered
by some pathogen you've never seen right
it induces the cells that produce either
that antibody or has those receptors on
its surface
to diversify to produce daughter cells
that are not alike they are actually
programmed to be not alike and then that
fraction of the daughter cells that is
best triggered then produces its own
daughter cell so you get this rapid
pattern of evolution right it's a
confusing language but it's called
clinical selection
well
not I mean it if you know the daughter
cells are different uh it's
and you have in your head what most
people have in their head about what a
clone means ah it's confusing language
well it's actually a little bit like our
uh many earlier discussions about why
chromosomes are not the end-all and
be-all of sex determination even in
humans where sex is determined through
chromosomes right the point is you we
tend we'll notice the pattern that there
is a chromosomal pattern that men tend
to be X Y women tend to be xx and so
strongly so that we tend to want to
synonymize them but as you point out
um the real the the thing that really is
not a broken pattern is that there are
two are more ancient than genetic sex
determination right is the gamete size
which actually dictates what is male and
what's female so the shortcut of saying
oh it's the chromosomes gets you in
trouble and in the same way here the
idea that clone means identical right is
not right what's actually happening is
you've got
um an asexual process that has a random
number generator triggered in it in
order to get diversity it's a cheat to
bypass sex as a mechanism for producing
diversity right so it really is clonal
and it really is selection in fact
um
Peter meadowar was one of the Pioneers
here Peter medowar who I believe got the
Nobel Prize he's a British biologist got
the Nobel Prize for discovering the
basis of graft rejection right graft
rejection being the result of the fact
that if you take a organ from somebody
who has your blood type so there's no
big antigen incompatibility and you
transplant it into you well it still
isn't self right they've spelled all of
the proteins differently and so your
immune system will attack it right and
so getting a match uh a molecular
electromagnetic match for you is
important which is why it's so hard to
find a donor right somebody had somebody
has to die who has that match before you
get an organ that you're not going to
reject
but in any case Okay so you've got these
cells that are capable of uh evolving to
get better but what that means is that
you have the rudimentary cells the
library the crude library of you know
it's not the Super refined tool that
fits the thing just so it's the
adjustable crescent wrench that fits it
kinda right it's that kind of thing but
that isn't nothing in fact it's keeping
you alive right that thing which is
always surveilling for looking for
hostile pathogens to get the place to
start the process of evolving a good
response is ever present right and so
anyway the antibodies in that response
is always available it's just not high
quality and the thing that vaccines do
and now I'm talking about Good vaccines
in which nobody would argue that they're
anything other than vaccines
what those things do is they provide an
advanced warning
right they provide a description of the
of the the Hostile entity in advance so
that that process of learning the
molecular signal the electromagnetic
signal of those antigens can be done
when you're not sick right or minimally
sick in the case of a uh of a attenuated
virus vaccine right so you do that work
when you're not challenged by the thing
and then you run into things like oh I
already know how to beat that in fact
I'm going to beat it I've got a head
start my immune system has a head start
on you because I haven't seen you before
but I've seen something like you enough
that I'm ready right and so presumably
we are
constantly being invaded by viruses and
other pathogens for which we already
have the formula and we never get any
symptoms because we beat them so quickly
right and so that's how it's supposed to
work but don't get the idea that you
don't have the immunity until something
either the infection or a vaccine gives
it to you that's just not right inside
of this discussion about antibodies
we have now started discussing different
classes of antibodies right we discussed
IGG which is the primary antibody
thought to be responsible at least in
the case of SARS cov2 and probably most
viruses for neutralizing these things
but that is what is induced by the early
inoculations
the problem is and many people have now
raised this in different ways that this
is not ideally the kind of immunity that
you want to stop transmission of this
thing and it may be that at some level
the very design of this vaccination was
doomed from the start not to stop
transmission because it's in the wrong
place right your lymph can be full of
immune cells that are well alerted to
this pathogen but if your mucosa aren't
brimming over with antibodies that
identify the pathogen as soon as it
lands it can still get into your lungs
and so
um the way to think about this the way
to listen for it is that the antibodies
the class of antibodies that are
responsible for mucosal immunity is IGA
not IGG right so
um anyway and you may also have heard of
ige which is the one that paradoxically
seems to produce nothing but trouble
right it produces allergies right places
where you have an immune reaction to
stuff that is not a pathogen and
um that's not good you can in fact be
killed by your own immune response to
something that is not a pathogen like a
bee sting you'll be overwhelmed with
your own uh inflammation I wonder if it
might not have been in an earlier era
when we weren't able to travel with such
magical alacrity a uh a measure of
localness
uh of you know if if if you are now
being exposed to something
at 10 or 20 or 30 especially or 40. uh
you've never been exposed to before uh
maybe you have strayed into territory
where other things are going to be new
as well
hmm
interesting if it would if you would
take it as some kind of a proxy for
something
um interesting and thought anything like
that quite possible
yep uh but
yeah actually you know it sort of fits
with um
the discussion of the repulsion that
people the physical revulsion that is
sometimes felt about uh
foreign
stuff Oh I thought you're gonna talk
about sick sickness oh well but that you
know let's put it this way
um amongst racists the belief that the
other is not only you know an economic
threat or a military but dirty
disgusting
um so anyway who knows maybe there is
some some history that would explain
that and it's not uh just
um a trick a propagandistic trick yeah
just an aside that I know you you're
still talking about IG
uh IG A and G here
um but one of the places where that
script gets very much flipped is in the
European arrival on the eastern coast of
North America where both Europeans and
Native Americans who they interacted
with perceived that the Native Americans
were very clean and the Europeans were
filthy and what the hell is wrong with
those people anyway the Europeans like
what what is wrong with those Europeans
how can they live like that right now it
is true and then of course you know
um
at the point that the Europeans were
Landing in North America the game was
already in some sense over as a result
of the pathogen that had spread due to
early contact
um but you know clearly at some level
the Europeans were a pathological threat
that they didn't even presumably
understand yeah um right which is a
fascinating and very very tragic story
um back to immunoglobulin yeah back to
immuno immunoglobinal so uh
immunoglobulin is just a synonym for
antibody
um and it's what the IG stands
forgot right
um and you should know so this would be
better done with visuals although most
of our uh followers are just listening
anyway but
um the
the fact is these antibodies which you
have seen diagrammed a million times as
little y-shaped proteins where the tips
of the Y are the thing that sticks to
the antigen and then the tail is what
dictates what class IGA IDE IGG Etc
um the antibody is
um in but that thing has a close
evolutionary relationship to The
receptors
that sit on the surface of the B cells
so you can imagine if a B cell is
producing antibodies and those
antibodies find their Target and they
land that doesn't tell the B cell that
produced them anything special they're
not you know in contact so there have to
be receptors on the cell itself so that
the cell itself knows ah wait it's my
time it's like the bank guard who you
know spends an entire career sitting in
the bank where nothing happens and then
finally the robber shows up and it's
like Ah that's what I've been training
for right
um
so anyway The receptors on the you know
the T cells and the B cells have an
evolutionary relationship they're not
independent right these are two versions
of variation The evolutionary variations
on a theme
and The receptors and the antibodies
have a relationship and anyway they're
in lives the the story but that's
probably almost enough to cap this off
for today purpose being really just to
get people used to the conversation
since I think we're about to end up
talking about whether this campaign made
any sense in the first place you know
did this campaign meaning this kind of
uh treatment that was sold to us as a
vaccine yes what campaign the
vaccination campaign right creating IGG
immunity in your lymph and blood was
that ever did anybody think that that
was going to arrest the uh the progress
of this pathogen and if so by what
mechanism right you know an IGA response
in the mucosa might have blocked
transmission and there's a way to induce
that which is to produce the
pseudo-infection or the attenuated
infection in the mucosa where the mucosa
learns this
lesson instead of your lymph
um which is to say a different drug and
delivered differently right a nasal
vaccine of a traditional sort right and
I will say you know yes we will be
accused of conspiratorial thinking on
the other hand we've seen an awful lot
of collusion just to obscure the truth
so I don't know why we would uh draw a
line but
um there is an aspect in which there are
several different lines of evidence that
you know Pharma was very excited about
this platform and it's easy to see why
because once this platform is something
that people accept then r d is just
slashed like you know you get it takes
it takes no time at all which was one of
the selling points right like wow we are
so lucky that we got this so fast
and you know you you have a chance to
replace literally years
right of r d and then I mean I don't
I don't know how it is that uh they are
going to continue to justify clinical
trials being abbreviated uh like they
did but um you know years into less than
a year is going to be quite a remarkable
cost savings well if they hadn't created
if the vaccines had been less
destructive than they turned out to be
or if they had been better at
controlling the story so that people
thought they were less destructive then
the answer is oh well this new platform
requires a whole new regulatory
structure because why would you spend
decades when the only thing you're
swapping out is a secant sequence right
so you can see their argument right you
can see them you know frothing at the
mouth frankly at the profits that
they're going to generate by trans
translating every vaccine into this new
platform and just you know shooting up
um
so it didn't work out that way and
hopefully people are awake enough or
enough people are awake enough that uh
you know
we'll say two brief things here one to
understand that as
fantastic as the potential of uh
inducing the production of uh uh
proteins using uh transfection with mRNA
as much as that has tremendous potential
a
we don't know that it can be done
usefully and there's a basic safety
problem that is going to accompany every
single attempt and the basic safety
problem is
you're going to make the patient's cells
produce foreign antigen and that is
going to get them targeted by the
patient's immune system and unless you
have some really sophisticated way of
keeping that damage to some tissue where
you can afford it it's game over right
it's not it's not worth it and so anyway
to my way of thinking
um
that's where the conversation has to be
have you solved that problem if so tell
us how you've solved that problem and
we'll talk about whether or not what
you're saying makes any sense or if it
sounds like PR right but until you solve
that problem uh well you've just seen a
totally predictable disaster
um and we're not doing that again so
hopefully
um so anyway it's it's it's that
question written over all sorts of
vaccines that you know that they
basically want to change the process on
foreign
[Music]